tribe who was Disraeli Disraeli was a
novelist Israeli with slice Prime
Minister and probably one of the major
figures of the 19th century in England
when was this picture taken the cheese
on the cover he was in his early 30s
though he looks younger he was then a
novelist and aspiring to be a politician
took him a long time he lost four
elections before he became a member of
parliament what years did he live
Disraeli was born 18 for he died in 1881
by the time he died he was probably the
most famous man in England and would
have been the famous most famous person
in England of Queen Victoria hadn't been
around and he was her favorite prime
minister why would he been the most
famous person if she had been around
well as twice Prime Minister as a famous
novelist as somebody who's always in the
public eye because of his audacity he
once said that success is the child of
audacity and he proved it and his own
lifetime where did the name Disraeli
come from
Disraeli was originally D ' is RA le why
than Disraeli was of Israel that is the
Israeli meant of Israel in other words
that identified his Jewish background
his father kept the name but he dropped
the apostrophe just out of
simplification where was his father born
his father was an Englishman his his
grandfather was born in Italy and
probably came from a Sephardic Jewish
background when the Israelis grandfather
came to England he came as a seller of
straw hats from Leghorn Italy and had
only one son the son was not interested
in selling hats or doing anything else
in the way of mercantile business and he
became a writer and this rarely followed
him as a writer when did you first get
interested in him i wrote a biography of
queen victoria published in 1987 and was
fascinated by the character of Disraeli
as he came across in the biography of
Victoria and
at that point I decided I wanted to
write about Israeli where you live where
do I live I'm at Penn State Senator of
Pennsylvania what do you do there I
teach I'm teaching a course in
biographical writing the semester and
how long have you been there a long time
I came to Penn State right out of Korea
the Korean War I was a young lieutenant
the Korean War and one of the other
sides of my writing has always been war
because I've been interested ever since
Korea so the last book of mine between
Victoria and Disraeli was one called
long day's journey into war about the
weekend of Pearl Harbor how many books
have you written over the years
Oh a lot I I would guess a dozen
biographies and possibly nearly that
many books of history cultural history
of various arts about world war one
about world war ii the Spanish Civil War
a book about my own adventures in the
Korean War and so on now I'm working on
a book on the summer of 45 about the end
of World War two
so perhaps I'll be back again here in a
year or so where's your home originally
Philadelphia on the Pennsylvania and all
the way a vaguely remember years ago
when Richard Nixon was president that he
used to refer to Disraeli uns maybe you
know this is one of his favorite
politicians in history what what has
happened is that a lot of politicians
have adopted Disraeli the same way in
America they've adopted Harry Truman in
other words they've adopted somebody who
is a feisty fighting character who came
out of nowhere who came out of a rather
low beginnings not an aristocrat by any
means and who fought his way up and so
you find Republicans having adopted
Truman over here and you find people of
both parties adopted Disraeli because
they liked the fighter they liked the
the fact that he had the audacity to do
what he did and where was he born
Disraeli was born in in London and his
father was a at least nominally Jewish
but about 12 years later just before
Disraeli that has been the man I'd
written about would have been Bar
Mitzvah the 13th birthday his father got
a visit from a friend who said you know
your son is never going to make it
anywhere because he's Jewish the laws
against Jews against Catholics against
Unitarians quite a lot of prejudicial
laws then prevented someone like this
rarely from becoming a public figure
through election to an office or
professions of various sorts and so his
father had him converted to the Church
of England Anglican Church at age 12 and
the other children - there were four
children so all four days Raley's became
nominally Anglicans and if it weren't
for that Disraeli would never have been
Prime Minister why because of those laws
against Jews and others forbidding them
to hold public office at that time the
law has changed over Disraeli
period as a public figure but he
couldn't have become a lawyer
he couldn't have become a judge he
couldn't have run for office and so his
father decided give him a chance and
ahead of mama we converted so Disraeli
had this schizophrenic background of a
tremendous loyalty to his Jewish
background and yet at the same time a
need to stress the fact that he was
legally entitled to the office as he was
running for now how did it was a law
stated positively or negatively the law
said that you had the square an oath on
the appropriate Bible and so if you if
you swear an oath for public office on a
King James Bible for example that would
have ruled you out if you were Roman
Catholic it would have ruled you out of
you're Jewish it would have ruled you
out in some other ways also so the laws
were not we're not very complicated
they just ruled you out if you would not
swear the proper oath you couldn't hold
office when the oath was a religious
house
when did they change for Catholics in
1829 for Jews it wasn't until 1858 and
how did they change they changed them by
changing the oath but I mean what was I
thought to fiying the oath was your ally
debate about it Oh tremendous debate the
debate about Disraeli and his brethren
becoming members of parliament was
fought over about every year sometimes
every other year one of the leading men
in England at the time was Lionel
draweth child who was the number one
banker in England and a very fine man
and one who ran for office from the City
of London I think five times elected
most of the time unanimously and he
couldn't take a seat because he would
not swear an oath on the Protestant
Bible the Anglican Bible is that the
same you say de Rothschild is it now
Rothschild in this country and others
roughly the and are they all descendants
of that they're all descendants of von
Rothschild in other words the German
family from Frankfurt and some of them
went to Italy some to France some of
them remained in Germany and when one
brother went to England and they
established branches of the bank in
England so that some of them were de
Rothschild some of them were von
Rothschild but basically they had
received titles of Baron from the
Austrian Empire and that entitled them
to the D or the bon me ask you about
some numbers how many books and were
they all nonfiction that Disraeli wrote
does rarely know does really was
novelist most of I'm sorry I meant
fiction but most of his books were a
fiction except that as in the case of
most novelists they begin by writing
about themselves
so this Raley's early heroes in the
first four or five novels were pretty
definitely Disraeli and when he would
write about somebody as having the two
greatest Spurs to ambition youth and
debt he was writing about himself he was
terribly in debt at the beginning of his
career for example his first not will
you say early on the book was written
Lee
20 20 or 21 yeah Excel it was a great
success until people discovered who
wrote it it was published anonymously
and people thought some great writer
must have written it and published it
anonymously and they praised that what
copies and then they discovered that
this young kid had written it and they
were embarrassed and it hurt that the
future novels of his for a while what
was in ailment vivian gray was his first
novel and he wrote a number of others
after that but also dealt with his own
background but in between he tried to
write one that would sell a lot of
copies in other words a sort of romantic
dream diction he called it the young
Duke and his father scoffed at this
saying what does what does Ben know of
Dukes and he didn't know anything about
Dukes but by the end of his life Queen
Victoria was ready to make him a Duke he
got as far as being Earl
he became Earl of Beaconsfield but he
was Prime Minister so he went from
obscure Jewish boy ineligible for office
to the end of his life Earl of
Beaconsfield and it could have had a
dukedom he wanted it how many novels
being right he wrote about a dozen and
what is very striking about his his
novels is that it made some of the other
novelists of the time very jealous some
of them were successful they were all
were very greatly talked about and
finally at the end of his life when he
was about to publish his last completed
novel Endymion he received the highest
son for signing the contract that any
novelist had ever received in England
and it made people like Anthony Trollope
and some of the other novelists who were
popular at the time very jealous they
couldn't imagine why somebody like this
rarely would be getting a kind of money
but he was a he was a public figure
people would read what he had to say
because it was Israeli even if it didn't
turn out the beer exciting novel now
today in this country if you went to the
bookstore which one or how many of his
novels would be there and which which
names we know the most I think only
three of them are in reprint right now
and there a group called the young
England trilogy that is they're known
collectively as a young England trilogy
that were published when he was a young
member of parliament the first one
called Coningsby the second one called
Sybil syb IL and the third called
tancrède and they all deal with a young
politician and the changes in the
aristocracy the popular democracy coming
in and the Sybil which is probably the
the best of the three was so successful
that people beginning their children
Sybil
there was a racehorse named Sybil it was
a song for Sybil it was a tremendous
success as Sybil was a girl of the
country who falls in love with and
eventually marries a member the
aristocracy and so you have a a merger
of the two nations
Disraeli called Sybil simple or the two
nations and he meant by the two nations
the rich and the poor and so the two
nations are emerged in Sybil as they
were never merged in real life but as I
said these were political dreams of
Disraeli turned into novels did you
write I mean did you read many of his
novels I read them all and working on
the non working on the biography and
found tremendous numbers of parallels
between his own life and his novels he
just put what he thought about what he
knew what he experienced but he would
have liked then all of these go into the
novels and possibly the most interesting
this way is that last one I mentioned
called Endymion
because in Endymion he relives his life
and he sees his life through
rose-colored glasses the way it would
have been if he hadn't been an upstart
Jew if he had only been just an upstart
and made it all the way to becoming
Prime Minister where the ladies fall in
love with him he was always a ladies man
and older women went after him in fact
he married a woman because he was so
much in debt he married in a widow who's
about 14 years
Eldar and didn't get him out of debt but
it helped a bit why not she didn't have
the money he was so deeply in debt he
speculated in the stock market zealand
woman right is the lady Marianne
Disraeli who had been the widow of a
member of parliament and that's young
Disraeli next to her she that's a
flattering picture of her she wasn't
really all that attractive at age 49
when he married her but he really needed
her money and he needed her house on
Grosvenor gate across from Hyde Park as
a place where he could entertain and be
a major politician but when you're
mid-30s and you marry a woman about 50
at a time in England when not is now a
fifty year old woman can still be very
attractive she was on her way down as a
beauty and was very jealous of him and
although there was a good deal of love
between them after a while she was also
very jealous she couldn't bear the idea
that younger women were interested in
him and at one point in his life perhaps
ten years after they married she broke
into his safes and Bureau drawers and so
on looking for love letters because she
was sure there were some and she found
those love letters he said he was
relieved by this but she found a lot of
material about his debts she had no idea
he was certain so much that how much by
our standards millions that is by our
buying power millions how did he do it
he kept borrowing money this is
unfortunately this is how this works
you're in debt and so you borrow money
and you borrow money at a higher
interest and then in order to pay that
back you have to borrow more money to
even higher interest so in the long run
he was so deeply in debt that the only
way he got out of it is that successful
bankers within the Conservative Party
who knew that he was a future prime
minister tried to figure out ways that
they could buy the debt off at very low
interest when he died it was the did he
have any money but when he died he was a
rich man because he had been a novelist
but he got no money from his wife
because his wife's money was all tied up
that is she was entitled to it in her
lifetime and he could spend the interest
on her income but when she died the
capital went to her relatives distant
cousins so he lost his house and he had
to move into a hotel for a while and
finally the one of the Rothschilds
offered him the house temporarily until
he could get a house of his own in
history how many biographies have been
written about Disraeli possibly a dozen
there were biographies written of
Disraeli before he became famous before
he before he became prime minister and
they were often very negative very
derogatory very any Semitic because he
never was lost the tag of being a Jew
for his life
how could he he was converted at 12 but
he be he remained Benjamin Disraeli
and if your name were Benjamin Disraeli
you're going to be identified with the
background from which he came how often
did he marry he only had one wife he
didn't remarry but curiously after his
wife died and he was in his late 60s I
think he was 16 about 69 at the time or
at least late 60s - women proposed to
him - the richest women in England one
of them was the Baroness Burdette Koontz
of the banking family the Koontz bank
she proposed to him and she said we'd be
the richest couple in England and he
said he wasn't interested the other
woman was the widow of the Earl of
Cardigan the Kaveri cardigan who we have
our cardigan sweaters named for but he
had been the one who ran the charge of
the Light Brigade was responsible for
that terrible disaster but he was a rich
man and as a second wife had married a
beauty who's very young and she survived
him by a lot of years she wanted to
marry Disraeli and he said she was too
notorious he big wasn't interested
how many affairs were you able to find
I'm not sure I found them all yet I
mentioned in the book that he appears to
had two illegitimate children by two
different women and just recently a lady
in England wrote to me to say that
there's a tradition in her family that
they're descended from an illegitimate
Israeli child and I have no evidence
this is the case but I'll follow it up
and maybe maybe it's true what years was
he Prime Minister Disraeli was Prime
Minister for the first time in 1868 and
the two children were born by the those
two illegitimate children one was born
1865 the year our Civil War ended and
the other was born in the next year how
do you know my the way they were his
children well in one case we'd have to
say smoking guns because this is before
the day when birth certificates were
required and even if there were required
birth certificates there would have been
ways to hide the fact and one of the
women lady Dorothea Neville was married
she hadn't lived with her husband for
years but she was a neighbor of Israelis
she lived across the street at the
Grosvenor gate and it was very very
close to Disraeli although 20 years
younger than Disraeli always known as a
very fast woman Disraeli was close to
her for a number of years and they had
been I think he was the father of her
last child she certainly wasn't involved
with her husband done and the child
named Ralph Neville was never owned up
as a Disraeli but the family says that
he looked like Disraeli and I've been
trying to get a picture out of the
family and so far been unsuccessful but
I do have a picture of the daughter and
that's in the book and she looks just
like Disraeli I think you may have I can
find it in my copy if you can't I've got
it right here and you see me going
through the pages urgently you just
passed it past the page all there is up
here and there you go on your left-hand
side where you can see the young
Disraeli and you can offer any Kate and
Kate's family still exists the family of
Kate is a very interesting story herself
Kate was married off
after it Israelis death and sent away
very likely with Rothschild money in
other words they help protect his
reputation and one of the Rothschilds
was executor Ford Israelis will and I
found in the Rothschild papers a
statement from the executor 'he's saying
that the the infant beneficiary is not
mentioned in the will and infant means
somebody who's a minor child and Kate
would have been a mire child then
and she wasn't mentioned in the will but
she apparently was taken care of if you
when you did his book and you interview
people so he has in the families well I
haven't met
Kate's descendants but I've talked to
them on the phone I've written letters
to them they live in New Zealand they
live in New Zealand they're a long way
off and the family sent me the picture
and the curious thing about this is that
a Kate's great-granddaughter who's still
around and in New Zealand is a novelist
she's followed the family profession and
she and her son consider themselves
Jewish although we have no idea who the
mother was in the case of this
particular child and the great-grandson
has literally converted back to Judaism
and considers himself to be a member of
Israelis family now I can't prove
anything more than the close resemblance
there is between Disraeli and Kate and
the fact that there is reference by the
lawyer who handled the will to their
being a child not mentioned in the will
and there's some other smoking guns but
there's only one child you see because
lady Dorothea Neville had a living
husband and so that child was covered
under the husband's will
and Ralph inherited money under his
legal father's will never needed
Israelis and he was a writer he wrote 30
books all of them so good I'm their
mother value but nevertheless he was a
writer too and apparently looked like
Disraeli
back to your book on Queen Victoria
what's the name of Victoria and in
Victoria and add to that biography
published by Dutton as is Disraeli
when did you start work on that and why
when Victoria yes in 1984
literally I went to an exhibit than
London I was working on another book
that I never wrote as a result of this I
went to an exhibit in London
of the documents and papers and
memorabilia dealing with Victoria's
consort husband Prince Albert and I was
fascinated by what I saw and decided I
wanted to write about that marriage
Victoria and Albert and began the book
and spent a great deal of time working
on it that came out in 1987 but at that
time I knew I wanted to write Disraeli
very often what happens is that a
subject of a book comes out of the index
to the last book but because you get
fascinated by somebody in the book and
you want to go on and write more what
was the first thing that caught your
attention when you were doing the
Victoria book about Disraeli I think the
first thing was how both Albert and
Victoria disliked him intensely they
disliked them he wasn't a gentleman at
what time in their lives they were
rather newly married they were married
in 1840 and this would have been about
1850 and he would then at that time what
47 years old he would have been in his
early 40s and still someone not yet
ready to make the big move into the
cabinet what was he doing then he was a
member of parliament and he was also
writing novels and saying things in the
novels that the aristocracy didn't
particularly care for so they knew my
current life counts today they met him
they had met him because he was a member
of parliament and would turn up at
social events that the king and queen
consort and queen had to be at what do
you mean by concert concert Victoria was
the queen she was queen in her own right
and inherited the throne the same way
that Elizabeth today is Queen Elizabeth
is queen and she doesn't have a king
Philip is is Prince Philip
burro in victorious time she would have
liked to have her husband named king or
king consort as they would have called
at them and the Parliament wouldn't
allow it he was a minor princeling from
a small German state Cobourg he wasn't
good enough for important enough he
wasn't English and so they wouldn't
permit it but he was a small prince or
Prince Lane and Victoria on in her own
right decided to name him Prince Consort
Prince husband in effect and that was
his title in the last years of his life
and how long was she Queen Victoria was
cleaned for 64 years from 1837 to 1901
she became Queen when she was 18 years
old so she was a good deal younger than
then Victoria Ben Disraeli was but there
was a sort of love affair going on a
very safe platonic kind of love affair
between Disraeli and the Queen after she
was widowed and well your picture there
of Disraeli of the Queen seated in
Windsor Castle she thought he was
wonderful
she said that he treats me like a woman
well Gladstone who was the rival prime
minister from the other party treated
her like a committee and she said she
was not a public meeting me an arrest on
the one on William Gladstone when was he
Prime Minister Gladstone was Prime
Minister for the first time just after
Disraeli his first prime ministry so
that was 1869 and he was Prime Minister
often on four times longer than Disraeli
was a Labour to the 1890s this party was
the Liberal Party this Raley's was the
Conservative Party and would he have
been the same liberal party that exists
over there today so well it what exists
today is the rump of what is left of a
once very powerful party the Israeli and
Gladstone had both been conservatives to
start with but Gladstone moved parties
in order to be able to have a chance as
Prime Minister he switched parties what
they think of each other they disliked
each other and 10
why and well first of all they were
rivals second Gladstone came from a rich
gentlemanly background and he considered
Disraeli an upstart Disraeli was that
audacious character that he said he was
he also was covertly ne Semitic and I
found in Gladstone's papers references
to his anti-semitism the fact that he
was he said at one point when Disraeli
replaced him as Prime Minister that Jew
is going to spend our surplus one
doesn't say these things if you're a
real liberal you also I just had Milton
to the page on 390 to say ignoring his
elevated moral posture on most other
matters Gladstone by the way is his
elevated moral posture was he known to
be he was gonna be old to be the the
epitome of dignity and an honor and
rectitude and so on a great high
churchgoer very very religious he wrote
religious tracts for that matter when
you say here that Gladstone at a public
dinner at Newcastle embraced the
slave-owning south and declarative its
president quote Jefferson Davis had made
an army and made a navy and what was
more had made a nation he never lived
that down he supported the Confederacy
in fact the Liberal Party for the most
part did support the Confederacy because
they represented the industrialists of
the north of England though the cotton
mills in particular they wanted the
slave cotton and Gladstone also was the
son of a sugar planter family that made
money through Jamaican slaves before the
slave trade was declared illegal so he
had a background of that sort and I
found Gladstone to be a tremendous
hypocrite and of course that's run into
trouble for me in England and reuse the
book because there are a lot of people
who think Gladstone was wonderful and I
have looked under the sofa and found
other things about Gladstone that I'd
rather not repeat Gladstone used to
chase prostitutes for example he claimed
he was he was reforming prostitutes
he'd go out even as Prime Minister he'd
go out at night and walk the streets
looking for prostitutes only pretty ones
only pretty ones interested in he would
give them Bibles and money take them up
to their rooms and exhort them to change
their ways and then he'd go home and
he'd whip himself because he had excited
himself too much and that was what he
was after and this isn't his diarrhea
and how did you find it this isn't his
Diaries in his dr. Gladstone siren and
and were they available to everybody
else to see like goodness yes why hadn't
they written it up because they wanted
to be kinder to Gladstone and they're
there the diaries are not published but
the facts are there what kind of outrage
have you gotten about this in England
well the outrage is largely that this
really was a bad man too in other ways
you say that I should have created
Disraeli as a bad man I don't think this
really was a bad man I think this really
was an ambitious man he was an ambitious
man and he had to be more audacious than
the others because he had all those
handicaps that he had to overcome and he
may have said things that he didn't
believe in well politicians do but I
think he was a man of tremendous courage
I go into the problems in his early
years that he he suffered from very
serious depression he never thought he
would amount to anything and he had such
severe depression that doctors and that
benighted age tried to treat that
depression by of all things depressing
him or that is they took a lot of blood
from him and then they gave him doses of
digitalis and digitalis slows down the
heartbeat so they were they were
treating depression by depressing him
and he he had at least two very serious
about said depression that he overcame
he overcame an awful lot of obstacles
debt in the millions by our standards
prejudice that was religious and social
severe depression and yet he triumphed
over all these he became one of the most
famous novelist in England and
perhaps the best known prime minister of
the century and Victoria's favorite when
Isaac Disraeli said of his son what does
Ben know about dukes he was right but he
heard a lot about Dukes what he has done
and you live in Pennsylvania in State
College where the University of Penn
State is yes what's it like there
what's it like it snowed a lot last time
I was there but it's a very pleasant
place to be what's it like though to
write a book is that where you wrote
your book well I wrote the book at home
at Penn State I did a lot of research
obviously in London because that's where
the stuff is and what does it like to do
work at Penn State it's a very
supportive atmosphere and I get a lot of
encouragement if I hadn't I wouldn't
have been able to do all the things I've
been doing how do you find time to teach
I find well I don't play golf and I
guess I don't have any other hobbies but
writing and so I keep at it and the next
book will be done the spring and after
that I don't know I haven't figured it
out yet it's the title of the next book
I don't have a title yet but it will be
about the end of World War two
as I said I move back and forth between
writing about war and writing about the
Victorian people do you use your books
at all and your teaching I'm teaching a
class and biographical writing the
semester and one of the books we're
going to look at is Victoria because
it's in paperback and so it's more
accessible to students and the reason
I'm using it is that if I'm going to
teach students how to do it at least I
can tell them how that one was done I
can't get into the minds of another
writer but I can give them some ideas
how mine are done and I tell them be
tough you don't like the way I did
something tell me why it's no good write
it better where'd you learn how to write
you learn how to write by writing and I
guess that's the only way one can one
can do it when you start teaching a
class in biographical writing but I
don't think that's how you learn how to
write I think you're right by writing
and writing and writing when AG start I
guess I wrote some stuff as a kid in
school but the first thing I wrote was
as an army officer in Korea I kept a
diary
and part of the diary was later
published as a book called the war in
the woods so I began serious writing I
think when I was in the Army and it's
not a matter as a professorial type to
publish or perish because that's not
necessary at this point but it's a
compulsion
just as Disraeli was compelled to be
famous I think that's all he was
interested in and I think that's what
critics are have against him he didn't
want to be the best Prime Minister in
whenever had he wanted to be famous he
didn't want to be the best novelist
thing whenever had he wanted to be a
famous novelist and but people often
live by compulsions I guess mine is to
write do you have any interest in being
famous by writings no I want to be read
I want to be read I don't want to be
read only by scholars who number maybe
30 to 300 and that's it if I'm going to
work very hard to try to reveal what
somebody was really like and I think the
person was a fascinating individual I
want to communicate that and I think
this really is just compellingly
fascinating as a human being and as an
achiever and so I I'd like people to
know about that what would what would
happen if he were here today in our
system where would he be politically
what would we think of NEPA to live in
this television age I think we'd have to
consider him something on the order of a
liberal Republican that is he was in the
Conservative Party but he was in the
liberal wing of his party
Disraeli was responsible for example for
what was called the second reform bill
which extended the the number of people
who are eligible to vote tremendously
made working-class people eligible to
vote and the Liberals hated him because
he succeeded in doing it where they
couldn't but sometimes as we discovered
when for example Richard Nixon was able
to recognize Communist China and create
relations with communist
but it often takes a conservative to
accomplish something that would be
consumed otherwise is very radical and
so it took Israeli go back to that time
period and he was the the Prime Minister
what was going on in the world in you
you wrote a lot about some Bismarck's
name is in the book and Charles Dickens
name and one like we like to think of
the the period between the end of the
pole eons of time 1815 in the Battle of
Waterloo and the beginning of the first
world war in 1914 as a century of
relative peace it wasn't the century of
relative peace any more than now it's
just that the bigger Wars didn't happen
in the early 1850s when Disraeli was in
in Parliament the Crimean War took place
which was a pretty good sized European
war the one I think we remember mostly
for Florence Nightingale having been
involved in helping the the sick in the
Russian then bulk an area that was 50s
there was a big mutiny in India toward
the end of the 50s the American Civil
War was in the 1860s Germany was being
forcibly unified through Bismarck as you
mentioned in the 1860s and Disraeli and
Bismarck had a fascinating relationship
they respected each other very
considerably but in order to do this
this mark had Wars with three different
nations first with Denmark and then with
Austria and then with friends so there
were three big Wars Disraeli and this
mark met again in the later 1870s in
Berlin for the Treaty of Berlin to try
to end the fighting in the Balkans
between the Turks and the rising
nationalities their repeat of what we're
having with Bosnia and Herzegovina and
so long I am during your book oh yes yes
that hasn't hasn't stopped and those
Balkan wars continued through the 1870s
when Disraeli was trying to stop them
right into World War one and here we are
back again so you'll see some familiar
names in there when you look at Bosnia
and Herzegovina and Serbia and so on
they were all going on
did benjamin disraeli ever come to the
United States no he didn't he never had
any interest in coming to the United
States he knew that his political
fortune had to be made in England I
think he was worried that if he left
England the backbiting about him would
be so strong that he would lose his
position and traveling meant being away
a long time back then you couldn't just
take the Concorde and fly over it was a
long and somewhat harrowing trip to go
over the Atlantic to the United States
and then come back again sometime later
he never made a trip that big but she do
say in the chapter I guess it's 25 1874
to 1875 that symbolically the first
major event of Disraeli Premiership was
he's being awakened at 6:00 a.m. on
February 27th with the news that General
Sir garnet Wolseley forces had captured
the shanthi capital of Kumasi now in
Ghana anyway in other words there were
great many African colonial wars also at
this time but the other thing I wanted
to which was important to this
discussion is that in the next page
there's a woman with the name of Jennie
Jerome of New York who comes into this
picture who was she
Jennie Jerome was Winston Churchill's
mother an American and she was a she was
the wife of an aspiring young
parliamentarian and as a result as she
became hostess to Disraeli on a number
of occasions and does really admire her
quite a bit but he admired pretty women
let me quote that I want to read was
that from her that you put in the book
when I left the dining room after
sitting next to Gladstone I thought he
was the cleverest man in England but
when I sat next to Disraeli I left
feeling that I was the cleverest woman
you see that's why Victoria liked him
too he knew how to treat a woman and he
was able to do this even when when his
own wife was jealous of him he was able
to soften her up and treat her this way
as well and so she would boast to people
about this Railly who was never really a
handsome man in his old age he might
have been as a young man they would
boast
picture hanging on the wall of a Greek
god of mood of course Greek god and she
would say oh that's nothing you should
see my Disney and his bath she was a
little flutter headed but but she was
very proud of her dizzy as she called
him in the in Demyan book de novel which
is it his last my last novel later on
the book you say the novel is rich in
dry wisdom of Disraeli six decades in
political and fashionable life what time
in his life do you rate this he wrote
this when he was in his last year's he
died in 1881 when he was 77 and he wrote
this in the later 1870 so he was already
in the 70s when he wrote this and he was
not the retiring type for example he has
somebody say in Endymion an ox and a
pasture has a pleasant life but he
doesn't want that kind of life field he
doesn't want to be put out to pasture I
don't know where this will working out
but I listed you list but I think I
counted something like 19 different
points about life and how you ought to
live them and I'll read a couple and see
if it works that you can if you can
relate them to his life would you say
these are what he thought how life want
to be lived I think most of them are the
way he thought life what will be lived
though of course he was writing a
dialogue for characters and he put my to
put dialogues in the mouths of the
character that he didn't like that would
be a different August Rico slant one as
a general rule nobody has money who
ought to have it well that goes back of
course to the Israelis attempt to get it
he he knew that he oughtn't to have all
those riches he was aiming for when he
was 20 years old I - what is the use of
diamond necklaces if you cannot help a
friend in the parliament he was very
indebted to women who either plunder
sold their jewels if necessary to help
him in public office to help them fight
old an election marry marriage is a
mighty instrument marriage was a mighty
instrument for him it saves his career
for life is a masquerade life is a
masquerade that one is that takes a
whole book to deal with it maybe this is
the
book The Masquerade is who are you at
the time that is you this is image
making the masquerade and he was
certainly in the process of being of
image making as a politician or his life
v desperation is sometimes as powerful
as and inspire as a genius as genius let
me read again desperation is sometimes
as powerful and inspire as genius there
are many times in his life when he had
to do what he had to do but because he
was desperate I mentioned the the
occasions when he was suffering from
depression he married his his wife I
think as much out of desperation as
anything else that worked out
fortunately six as for religion
generally if a man believed in his maker
and does his duty to his neighbor in my
mind at a sufficient
I think that was cos Raley's religion
that is he had he'd he may have gone to
church because politically he had to but
I think his ideas about religion were
much more liberal denied that a church
or religion rather is a maker of ethics
and he wasn't much of a theologian but
then neither was Victoria Victoria had
no theology seven it is not good taste
to believe in the devil well I think
that just represents his dislike of
evangelical religion eight a little
knowledge of the world is a dangerous
thing especially in literature I think
that this really as a novelist practiced
what he preached nine I prefer the
Society of a first-rate I prefer the
society of a first-rate woman to that of
any man he practice what he preached
there too
he told a number of people that the best
way to learn what the world was like was
to talk to an intelligent woman and
Oscar Wilde used to repeat some of
Israeli sayings as his own and that was
111 never dine out in a high-neck dress
it was fashionable of course for women
in high society who were very low-cut
dresses and if you wanted to be
interesting you were the low-cut dress
not the high one by the way this is from
a demi
is not a little bit how did it sell
Endymion as I said got the biggest
advance on signing a contract that any
novelist had ever gotten
and by the time Disraeli had died which
was less than a year later it made the
money back and this beginning like a
profit you have any idea what the
novel's so for in those days novels
usually sold for a shilling sometimes
they sold for a shilling and a half but
relatively because our change of money
values it would have been the same as a
novel today so you might have paid
twenty dollars for a novel by our
standards today another saying you took
out of Endymion is only let a man be
able to drive into Bamford on market day
and get two of three linen Draper's to
take off their hats to him and he will
be happy enough and always ready to die
for our glorious Constitution he says
really little pride in yourself and if
one of the things you get in your life
is a sense of pride then you've achieved
something as this man twelve the most
precious stone must be cut and polished
that that was this Raley's life he he
knew that he was a man of some genius
but he also knew that he had the
sophisticated and the little help of a
lot of women he did how much education
give you there was mostly self education
he went to school private schools
because there were no public schools
till he was about sixteen and then he
was apprenticed out to a lawyer a firm
of lawyers and which he lasted a couple
of years never practice law never made
it to the end and he worked for a
newspaper briefly but largely he was
self-employed by writing thirteen
without tax you can learn nothing tack
teaches you when to be silent I'm afraid
he hasn't learned that one well enough
he was too feisty to be as tactful as he
ought to be 14 I think life would be
very insipid if all our lots were the
same he was ambitious and obviously he
felt that you need the drive of ambition
to get somewhere you he quote there's a
limit to quality in that respect
equality of opportunity is one thing but
you need the drive of the ambition to
more 18 no one can be patient who is not
independent this was the problem for a
politician in particular then and it may
still be for politicians until we get
public financing of Elections if you're
independent you can then run for
election if you're independent you can
do things you want to do but if you have
to make a living this is going to keep
you from fulfilling many of your
ambitions finally your last quote is
every post session must end well that's
a good one to end on isn't it every pro
session must end he knew that it was
going to stop the beagles were going to
stop playing for him and it did stop he
became prime minister for the last time
when he was in his 70s and his ministry
ended less than a year before he died so
the procession ended now he was in the
House of Commons for how many years
total he was in the House of Commons in
1837 another year that was that Victoria
became queen until he died he never left
the House of Commons he was reelected
every time he ran but didn't he became a
lord but he was I'm sorry he was in
Parliament I shouldn't have said House
of Commons you're right when he became
Earl of Beaconsfield in 1876 which was
five years before he died he moved over
for the House of Lords so he was in
Parliament but the last five years were
spent in the House of Lords
how about Gladstone did he ever become a
lord Gladstone refused he was the he was
the the great commoner he wanted to be a
common man on the friend of the common
man and so he refused even to be
knighted and so he remained for a pure
William Gladstone till the end of his
days Churchill tried that for many years
it was only when he was in his very late
years that he agreed to be Sir Winston
and Churchill I think in part didn't
want a title that would be inheritable
and in in our days now you can get a
life peerage so that the title is not
inherited
Disraeli had no illegitimate children
and his day when he was made an Earl
Victoria said if you would like I will
issue a special ruling that will enable
your nephew he had only one male nephew
named Cunnings be after his novel if
you'd like I would have love Coningsby
to inherit your Eldon and Disraeli says
he'll have to work for it he didn't
believe in that service I guess he was
he did not want people who did not earn
their honours to heaven how many times
did he run for the House of Commons
before he got elected four times in the
same constituency no they differed a
little bit but two were in the same
constituency what the one he finally won
from and he he was just too antagonistic
to the electorate he thought that he
could win on the basis of feistiness and
the fact that he was a genius he didn't
know you had to be trusted and he also
didn't know you had to buy the votes and
eventually before the English reforms
came along he'd managed to borrow enough
money to buy enough votes that he got
elected it's a little harder to buy
votes now did he and they William
Gladstone every debate no they never did
except in the House of Commons where
they would have debated along with other
people but they did answer each other
one can't call it as so much a debate
because other people were involved but
they did answer each other and they
probably were the two best speakers in
the House of Commons and their time and
people would fill the place to listen to
them talk he said that he would be a
liberal Republican in this country how
tall was he how tall was he he was
rather short he was about five feet six
and that was average height for his time
you referred to him at one point is
having a drawl of some kind he seems to
have developed a drawl because he
thought that it was aristocratic and he
wanted to speak in an aristocratic
fashion and part of the drawl I think
was that if you slowed your manner of
speech it gave you time to think ahead
and that enabled him
- to speak with greater effectiveness by
the way all these characters in this
book which one's your favorite besides
Israeli
besides Disraeli somebody we haven't
mentioned at all one of the ladies who
was very friendly with him and who
admired immensely and that's Charlotte
the Rothschild who was Lionel the
Rothschilds wife he would often go over
and visit her on his own to talk to her
he admired her mightily and I think he
admired her because he liked to hear
intelligent women talk and he often went
to talk with her
who is the bike countess Beaconsfield
that was his wife Mary Ann Mary Ann we
didn't go into that after Disraeli was
Prime Minister for the first time he was
entitled to an earldom if he wanted it
and the Queen asked him if he wanted it
had the rank of nobility and he said no
but my wife is very old and she probably
will not live to see me prime minister
again I would like her to be honoured to
her own right and she thought and her
her advisers thought that it was a
scandalous thing to do that one
shouldn't do this but this early
insisted and so she became by Countess
of Beaconsfield in her own right and was
able to wear a car net and had the fancy
stationery and a coat of arms and she
loved it her last year's what would you
say he accomplished for Great Britain I
think he accomplished bringing the
average person more into the political
scene than had ever been done before
particularly was what I called the
second reform bill it brought the
working class into the electorate as had
not been done before in his second prime
ministry he mainly consolidated things
he was interested in pure food and drug
laws improving sanitation facilities
improving education and so on he didn't
have big breakthroughs in the second
ministry he was trying to improve a lot
of society what's new in this book
what's new in this book compared to all
the other biographies I think
a Israeli demand is elicited here more
than ever before Israeli the man and in
particular I think how his being a Jew
drove him and how it affected him in the
public eye I think in both ways it was
tremendously important that is the
public's perception of him as a Jew no
matter what baptism occurred early in
his life and his own perception of how
that was going to affect his career he
used it he did not let try to the stand
in his way
here is the dedication for this book you
have it in memory of my father Benjamin
Weintraub and my father-in-law Benjamin
Horowitz who each share a name with
Israeli how long have they been gone I
guess about a dozen years in the case of
my father-in-law my father died when I
was working on my doctorate and I was
much much younger what do you remember
about Bowden and what I remember most
about my father was that he was a
tremendous reader although he had very
little education I think he didn't have
education formal education beyond the
fourth grade but when he died in his
sleep he was found
reading Shakespeare's Othello about your
father-in-law my father-in-law was busy
all his life and that wasn't wasn't the
great reader that my own father was but
he was got a very strong figure in the
family and somebody admired a great deal
what was the toughest thing about
writing this book the toughest thing
about writing this book was not to get
diverted into writing too much about all
those other interesting people who turn
up in Desiree's life perhaps I shouldn't
have even been diverted by the two
illegitimate children into half a
chapter because one doesn't want a book
to get too long you want to be able to
lift it up in your it in your lap and
hold it and be able to read it and so
there comes to be a practical limit as
to how long a book should be the first
official biography of the only official
biography with Israeli
six volumes and I don't think it went
into nearly as much detail about what he
was really like as this one does now you
said that Victoria led to Disraeli is
there anybody in the index of this book
that might lend itself to a biography in
feature several but I don't think I want
to get into them because I don't want to
give anybody out there any ideas before
I got started myself what about William
Gladstone but I will never write about
William Gladstone I found him to be very
unsatisfactory dirty old man and he's
not for me well not it will not be
William Gladstone she didn't find
Israeli to be a dirty old man no no no I
found Disraeli to be far more of a
gentleman and far more their liberal
minded individual than the so-called
liberal who was Gladstone so I came I
came away disliking glads don't even
more heartily than I did when I stopped
writing Victoria Victoria once wrote a
letter to Gladstone telling him that she
was to visit him as Prime Minister up at
her Balmoral Castle in Scotland and she
said buy a new suit of clothes don't put
it on don't wear it until you come up
and visit me and then then put it on and
she went had some detail about this she
said he was a dirty old man in effect
she didn't want it to be near the man
who had been consorting with these
prostitutes and so she said I want you
to come clean when you come today here's
the book it's called Disraeli a
biography former Prime Minister of Great
Britain written by Stanley Weintraub
thank you for joining us you're welcome
fled to beer